vamos a resolver ahora el problema 21
dice en la siguiente figura n es un
número entero
cuál es el menor valor posible para n a
este problema está bien interesante
tiene una idea que se aplica en muchos
problemas y la idea es la siguiente si
tenemos un lado en un triángulo entonces
ese lado no le puede ganar a la
combinación de los otros dos lados o sea
a la suma para este problema podemos
pensarlo de la siguiente forma si
queremos hacer n lo más pequeño posible
lo que tenemos que hacer es empezar a
bajar y a bajar esta altura para que se
vaya acercando a esta base piénsalo por
ejemplo si tuviéramos si tuviéramos este
lado de aquí y este lado de acá entonces
hay claramente la n se hace más pequeña
más pequeña acá acá y si éste sube
muchísimo entonces la n se hace más y
más grande entonces para analizarlo más
pequeño que puede ser n lo que conviene
es pensar qué sucede si este punto cae
sobre esta base vale cae sobre esta base
en este caso nos quedaría un triángulo
apachurrado vamos a decir que es un
triángulo degenerado vale es un
triángulo degenerado porque no es un
triángulo de adeveras todas
el área la paramos en esta línea de acá
pero bueno qué sucedería en este caso si
a pachu ramos que apresuramos este punto
hasta acá abajo entonces tenemos que
esto vale n que esto vale n y por lo
tanto en este caso n sería igual a 7.5
7.5 pero eso de ahí tiene dos problemas
para empezar ni siquiera es un triángulo
bueno es un triángulo degenerado es un
triángulo apachurrado y otro problema es
que en él no quedó entero pero bueno lo
que sí podemos hacer es aumentar tantito
n aumentar tanto n entonces n tiene que
ser mayor que 7.5 que 7.5 aumentarlo
hasta que llegue al primer entero para
encontrar el menor valor posible y el
primer entero que es más grande que 7.5
es 8 entonces el mínimo valor de n sería
n igual a 8 vamos a ver si está en las
opciones 117 no 8 aquí está la respuesta
correcta es c y esta idea es súper
importante vale si tenemos un triángulo
entonces ninguno de los lados le puede
ganar a los otros dos lados combinada
bueno vamos a pasar al problema número
22 el problema 21 ya me gustó más que
los otros que veníamos haciendo de hecho
a lo mejor hasta me tenga que retractar
había dicho que estos problemas no
ayudan a desarrollar nada nada de la
intuición pero en realidad del 21 pues
sí sí ayuda un poquito a entender un
poco más a los triángulos bueno entonces
problema número 22 dice cuál de los
siguientes conjuntos de números puede
representar las longitudes de los lados
de un triángulo misma idea tenemos que
ver que un lado no le gané a la suma de
los otros dos por ejemplo aquí 5 le gana
2 más 2 entonces no vamos a poder tener
triángulos con la 2 225 podemos pensarlo
por aquí con un poco más de calma o sea
podemos tener ahí un lado 2 aquí otro
lado 2 y la máxima distancia entre estas
dos tache citas es cuando quedan
alineadas con el punto o sea cuando
queda como por acá por acá este lado que
mide 2
este lado que mide 2 y entonces la
máxima distancia que puede tener el
tercer lado es 45 no vale entonces este
no esta opción no es correcta b 3 3 y 5
pues aquí sí podemos tener un triángulo
con medidas 3 3 y 5 3 y 3 le gana 5 5 y
3 le gana 3 entonces no hay ningún
problema podemos verlo de la siguiente
forma podemos tener un triángulo así con
la 2 3 3 y este tan chiquito como
querramos simplemente vamos haciendo
este ángulo más y más pequeño y de ahí
podemos pasar hasta los triángulos que
son muy muy obtusos de lados 3333
digamos algo de este estilo y este
tercer lado puede ser tan cercano como
queramos está quedando un poco feo pero
bueno este tercer lado puede ser tan
cercano como queramos a 6 vale entonces
pasamos desde lo más chiquito que se
puede hasta lo más cercano a 6 y por lo
tanto si existe un triángulo de medidas
3 3 y 5
este de acá no se va l 4 y 4 3 4 4 y 8
no porque misma idea podemos tener aquí
4 aquí 4 y lo máximo sería 8 08 no puede
ser porque nos quedaría un triángulo de
generado un segmento y finalmente de
tampoco puede ser misma idea el 15 le
gana a 55 entonces no hay triángulos de
la 2 5 5 y 15 va entonces la opción
correcta es ve el problema número 23
problema número 23 en el diagrama
adjunto las rectas paralelas paralelas
l&m son cortadas por la transversal que
va entonces este es un problema clásico
de paralelas con transversales pregunta
cual enunciado acerca de los ángulos 1 y
2 debe ser cierto
bueno antes de ver las opciones vamos a
jugar un poquito con los ángulos a ver
para dónde los podemos pasar tengo un
vídeo de del juego de los ángulos
entonces más o menos vamos a hacer eso
entonces aquí tenemos este ángulo 1 este
ángulo 1 es correspondiente con este de
acá con este de acá porque este es una
transversal a estas dos paralelas
entonces éste
la misma medida que el ángulo 1 ya me
estoy aprendiendo las definiciones que
ellos usan creo
para entonces la medida de este ángulo
es igual a la medida del ángulo 1 y por
lo tanto ya podemos compararla con este
ángulo de acá que es el 2 y observemos
que este con este suman 180 grados y por
lo tanto son ángulos suplementarios
suplementarios
varios vale dos ángulos son
suplementarios cuando suman 180 grados
aquí suman 180 grados porque estos dos
combinados forman la línea m el ángulo
en la línea m va entonces son ángulos
suplementarios vamos a ver este que
sucede aquí el ángulo 1 es congruente al
ángulo 2 no pues quién sabe verdad este
no tiene por qué ser congruente a éste
ve el ángulo 1 es el complemento del
ángulo 2 esto suena un poquito a lo que
dijimos pero complemento es otra cosa
complemento querría decir que el ángulo
1 con el ángulo 2 suman 90 grados
entonces esto tampoco es lo que queremos
el ángulo 1 es el suplemento el
suplemento del ángulo 2 si esto es
exactamente lo que dije son ángulos
suplementarios entonces el 1 es el
suplemento del 2 y viceversa entonces la
opción correcta sería c y d
ángulo 1 y ángulo 2 son rectos no esto
no tiene nada que ver hasta está medio
tonto aquí no hay nada de ángulos rectos
entonces pues ya está
la respuesta correcta es el problema
número 24 vamos avanzando le a buen
ritmo qué valores de a&b hacen que el
cuadrilátero mn
sea un paralelogramo mn o sea un
paralelogramo esta queda paralela a esta
que está queda paralela a esta de acá
bueno pues como platicábamos antes en un
paralelogramo los lados opuestos los
lados opuestos son congruentes de hecho
te reto a que intentes dibujar un
paralelogramo en el cual los lados
opuestos no sean congruentes no se va a
poder porque de hecho se prueba que si
los pares de lados opuestos son
congruentes pero bueno con eso en mente
podemos establecer algunas ecuaciones
con
y algunos números por ejemplo de la
congruencia de mn con o p obtenemos que
3 a 3 a -2 b -2 b es igual a 13 es igual
a 13 y con la congruencia de mp con n
obtenemos que 4 a 4
+ b es igual a 21 a 21 entonces ahora
tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones
lineales en dos variables con este con
dos cuestiones entonces básicamente este
es un problema de álgebra disfrazado
vamos a resolverlo déjame multiplicar la
ecuación de aquí abajo por 2 por 2 con
la idea de cancelar las veces entonces
nos quedaría ochoa + 2 b es igual a 42 y
ahora déjame sumar esta con esta estas
dos las vamos a sumar y vamos a poner lo
que queda aquí abajo entonces 3 a con 8
a 11 al menos 2 b con dos veces cancela
es fuera la idea entonces son sea es
igual a 13 42 o sea a 55 dividiendo
entre 11 de ambos lados obtenemos que es
a cinco puestos y ya entonces ya tenemos
el valor de a que se lo podemos
sustituir aquí arriba en la que queramos
para obtener el valor de b lo voy a
sustituir lo voy a sustituir pues en
esta de aquí en la primera va entonces
tres por cinco o sea 15 3 es 15 menos
dos veces b es igual a 13 vamos a pasar
el 3 restando y el menos dos [ __ ] ya
sumando entonces nos quedaría 2 es igual
a 2 b y dividiendo entre 2 de ambos
lados nos queda que b es igual a 1
entonces ya tenemos la respuesta
la respuesta es igual a 5 b igual a 1
si está a 5 b igual a 1 la respuesta es
ve muy bien el problema número 2525 el
cuadrilátero bsd es un paralelogramo si
los ángulos adyacentes son congruentes
cual enunciado debe ser cierto aunque
hay déjame dibujar un paralelogramo un
poco más bonito con la herramienta de
línea recta bueno a lo mejor no quede
tan paralelogramo pero pero más o menos
se entiende la idea verdad va a ser para
trabajar aquí entonces dice el
cuadrilátero abs de b es de es un
paralelogramo si los ángulos adyacentes
adyacentes son congruentes no dice
cuáles adyacentes pero bueno si estos
dos son adyacentes este todos van a ser
congruentes ahorita vemos por qué cual
enunciado debe ser cierto entonces lo
que nos están diciendo es que este
ángulo digamos que mide x y este ángulo
que mide digamos miden lo mismo o sea
que x es igual hay déjame ponerlo aquí
que éste también tienen medida x bueno
lo que vamos a hacer es prolongar
para pensarla como una transversal de
adén ibc o sea déjame prolongar para acá
ade para cada vez e íbamos a prolongar
por acá
ab vale vamos a prolongarlo por acá
entonces la idea la idea es utilizar
esta transversal lo que vamos a hacer es
pasar este ángulo x para acá y eso lo
podemos hacer porque son ángulos
alternos internos en las paralelas este
ángulo es congruente a este de acá vale
pero qué sucede entonces aquí tenemos un
ángulo equis y aquí también tenemos ese
mismo ángulo x que juntos están haciendo
esta línea por lo tanto son
suplementarios y así tenemos que 2x es
igual a 180 grados y por lo tanto x es
igual a 90 grados entonces todos los
ángulos del paralelogramo son de 90
grados y por lo tanto es un rectángulo
vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan a el
cuadrilátero a veces d es un cuadrado
pues no sólo vimos que es un rectángulo
y no hay nada que nos diga que sus
cuatro lados son iguales entonces pues
no quién sabe quién sabe si es un
cuadrado b el cuadrilátero abc d es un
rombo pues otra vez no tenemos la nada
que nos permita concluir que sus lados
son iguales entonces rombo quién sabe
se el cuadrilátero abc d es un
rectángulo pues si eso es justo lo que
probamos verdad todos los ángulos son de
90 grados entonces es un rectángulo la
respuesta correcta es si finalmente a
veces es un trapecio isósceles nada que
ver nada que ver vale muy bien entonces
con esto terminamos este vídeo vamos a
continuar con el problema 26 en el
siguiente